a workable system that protects refugees  that's to aim of a revised law em ups  are voting on it should also ensure all  EU states share the responsibility for  asylum seekers the Panama papers scandal  blew the lid off offshore bank accounts  a special inquiry committee set up to  investigate the revelations delivers its  final report nine out of ten Europeans  think the privacy of their emails and  instant messages should be guaranteed  Parliament is updating data protection  rules to include new forms of  communication the posting of workers is  integral to the internal market but  rules obsolete lawmakers are revising  them to create a level playing field for  companies and protect the rights of  posted workers can't serve the uterus  cervix and breast affect many women any  P's assess the e use current strategies  in place to help fight cancer in women